[Music]
have you seen the new pinocchio trailer
no
okay
royce video
i'm doing it
thank you though
this new overlay's taking a bit to get
used to
[Music]
disney
the studio we're talking about studio
that brought you beauty and the beast
and the lion king disney both the good
and the bad ones
remember the live action beauty and the
beast bro
[Music]
tom hanks is playing geppetto
i think i think he's playing pinocchio
[Music]
hey uh tom hanks when are you going to
start treating your boy chat like a real
boy
what the problem is every time chet lies
he gets [ __ ] yeah
you know what grows his bank account
his dick
what do you call a fire with no friends
star light star bright
first star i see is tom hanks becoming
the new patrick
stewart is he the new old guy that's
gonna start doing patrick stewart's cool
izzy have you seen picard
well
for me tonight
i wish i may
i wish i might
have the wish
i wish tonight
when you
wish which makes sense because this is
gonna look like you ordered pinocchio
one wish
yeah exactly
[Music]
who's voicing jiminy cricket
joseph gordon levitt no he's probably
pinocchio
frozen who's voicing jiminy cricket
[Music]
the thing is like tom hanks wants
pinocchio to be real so he could [ __ ]
him
yeah what's what's going to be their
angle i i don't oh you're about to see
it oh you haven't seen the angle yet no
i don't know yeah so joseph
gordon-levitt is jimmy cricket oh who's
playing pinocchio
uh
or is this going to be an entire movie
that just follows geppetto and not
pinocchio because why would you call it
pinocchio he's in the watch
that's the uh there you go is that is
that what you were talking about marsh
did i pretty much get close on what you
were
what you were referring to here may i
uh and there it is
also uh benjamin evan einsworth is
pinocchio i don't know i have no idea
so every like fairy godmother in every
work of fiction now is going to be a
sassy gay black guy
yeah and not only that i
i did tweet out i did i retweeted the
trailer and all i was yeah but why isn't
pinocchio black
and somebody sent me a joke i'm i'm not
allowed to say who sent me the joke but
i'm allowed to say the joke okay
this person is somebody who probably sh
doesn't want anyone knowing they're
saying this joke that's all i'll say
okay but tell me off the air of course i
will all right
if because i i tweeted why isn't
pinocchio black and this person wrote if
pinocchio was black his nose would get
his nose would get whiter every time he
lied
hold on
okay it makes sense right yeah that
makes a lot of sense
it's very funny that one got me oh [ __ ]
dude this doesn't seem right because
when i look a black person bald uh hello
alopecia much
sorry go ahead frozen oh yeah we sure
that's not just what's her face what
no because she's not she's not at all
times belittling will smith that's how
you know it's not yeah according to the
wikipedia right
this is cynthia er erivo okay
it's
supposedly an actual woman
that's a woman apparently
really are we sure how are we sure
because that looks like all and it
identifies as queer
that looks like omar from the wire yeah
it doesn't identify as uh as trans
no okay
you excited for pinocchio no
all right well we tried